So let's talk about cancer. So what is cancer?
So cancer isn't something that, you know, you catch, you can't get cancer from somebody that has cancer.
So we have to go back to kind of the cellular biology a little bit.
Every cell in your body might have a few different types of cells,
but almost all the cells in your body will replicate a new cell
over a period of time, typically about six to 12 weeks.
So let's use your liver. Let's use my liver, for example.
So you take out my liver, my liver cells about every six weeks that liver cell replicates a new cell.
And then the old liver cell or the mother cell, you could say, dies.
And then six weeks later, this cell will replicate a new cell and then this old cell will die.
That's normal physiology, okay?
So that's really what normal aging is.
So you age because your skin cells will replicate another skin cell.
And every time it does, and it's slightly degenerate, depending on your diet and your stress level, et cetera, et cetera.
And so that's what normal aging is.
So by liver, it's replicating another liver cell and this cell is dying.
Now it doesn't just automatically, magically die.
There's a process that takes place in order for that cell to go through what's called normal program cell death,
or what we call apoptosis.
So apoptosis, normal program cell that takes place because of a chemical reaction inside that cell.
That cell, every one of your cells has a membrane eroded, that's cell membrane.
And on that membrane are thousands of different receptors.
And you can think of a receptor as kind of a, as like a lock.
Like the door back there, there's a little lock that you can put a key into and you can open up the door then you can go in the door.
So think of a receptor as that.
So thousands of different receptors for all sorts of different chemical reactions that need to take place inside that cell.
So in order to get nutrients in the cell, a key goes into what receptor site opens it up and puts nutrients in the cell.
In order to get insulin in the cell, that's a receptor that most people are familiar with.
In order to get glucose into the cell, insulin is the key.
You could say to the lock for the insulin receptor to open it up and put glucose inside the cell.
So it is with the normal program cell death that has to take place every time that cell replicates a new cell, this cell is supposed to die.
Well, there are what are called apoptotic receptors in the cell membrane.
Vitamin D is one of those keys that can attach to an apoptotic receptor.
There are many more, but vitamin D goes in and opens up and turns on, in this case, the apoptotic process.
That's why the president of Harvard Medical School, about two or a half years ago, came up with a published paper in the AMA journal that said,
Vitamin D is the best no drug called in a drug against cancer that we know.
It's not a drug, it's actually a horrible.
And it acts as apoptotic stimulant.
It stimulates normal program cell death.
So vitamin D will keep to that example.
We'll go into that lock and turn that key.
It turns on this process inside the cell.
A whole bunch of different chemical reactions take place in order for the cell to implode and die.
Well, we want that to take place every six weeks.
After this cell reproduces another cell, we need this cell to die.
But things can happen, right?
Things can get attached to those receptor sites that we don't want attached to those receptor sites.
And then they don't allow vitamin D to enter into that key that enters the lock.
So apoptotic poptosis doesn't take place.
So three things have to take place in order for a person to have a diagnosis of cancer.
This is the first one.
Something blocked or stopped the process of normal program cell death.
Something blocked apoptosis.
So normally, by liver cell, reproduces another cell and the process of normal program cell death is stimulated.
The cell breaks up, it breaks up, it dies.
My limb system carries it away.
All is good and well.
So in order for me to have a diagnosis of cancer, that has to take place first.
That process needs to be broken.
And there's all sorts of possible reasons why that could be broken.
But that has to be broken.
In truth, it's broken on all of us at different times.
My liver cell may not reproduce another cell.
It doesn't go through apoptosis.
It lives another six weeks and it reproduces another cell.
It lives another six weeks and reproduces another cell.
And it finally goes through apoptosis.
Do I have cancer?
No.
Do I have the start of it?
Yes.
I have that first stage got broken.
But it finally went through apoptosis until it died.
What was the herb?
Well, that may deal by livers.
It's a little bit bigger after 50 years.
So what?
Yes.
Can vitamin D deficiency be one of those blood?
So vitamin D deficiency can be an issue with cancer patients.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So everybody has that happen at different times.
You might not have it happening.
If you're livered out, you're split later, you know, whatever.
That's happening with everybody.
So the comet does everybody have cancer?
Well, yes.
Cancer by definition is the second step breaking.
So the first step has to break.
And then the second step is, like I said,
if that only reproduced another cell every six weeks,
no harm, no fall, we're not going to end up with issues.
But the second problem is that they have to have a sped up replication cycle.
So the replication cycle has to have the gas fully known on the accelerator.
So now it's not reproducing the cell every six weeks.
Now it's reproducing six cells a day.
So the poptosa cycles broken and the replication cycles broken.
Now this is reproducing, reproducing, reproducing, reproducing, reproducing, reproducing.
Now we have by definition of the American Cancer Society
at every medical textbook this person has cancer.
And this even takes place in every one of us.
So first thing needs to be broken, second thing needs to be broken,
but there's one other thing needs to be broken
in order for you to finally have a diagnosis of cancer.
And that is, we have our one final failsafe method of keeping us from getting cancer.
So I might have a broken apoptotic cycle.
And I have a broken replication cycle.
It's reproducing, reproducing.
But if I have this third thing in place, I'll never get cancer.
And that is, guess what we just talked about last hour.
Your immune system.
What does the immune system do?
And it does really well?
Kill things.
So your immune system, purpose is to kill what's called an antigen.
That which shouldn't be in the body.
So it sees a bacteria.
Oh, let's kill it.
Kills it.
Oh, that's not there.
Let's kill it.
It sees this rapidly replicating mass of cells.
It goes, what the heck is that?
I don't know.
But let's kill it.
So you need a healthy immune system to not get cancer.
If you have a super healthy immune system and you go ahead and put composites in your teeth,
and eat barbecue and food, and you know, drink from plastic cups,
and do all the things that you could read every single day in the newspaper
that all this causes cancer to.
Newsprint.
Right?
It's like you can like move.
Like, I'm going to move.
So where are you going to go?
It's like, how do you get away from our corrupt government?
Find one that isn't?
Good luck.
Sorry.
But there isn't any way I get away from this stuff.
Yeah, you have to use wisdom.
If I go to like, you know, be eating McDonald's every day?
No.
But isn't it going to kill you if you eat McDonald's once a month?
You're going to have a balance.
And I never promote my patients to be so out of balance that they can't even live in this world.
I mean, you just can't live that way.
I don't live that way.
And I want to ask anybody else to live that way.
You have to have a balance.
But you have to also use wisdom.
So we want to use as much wisdom as possible in dealing with this.
So in order for a person to get cancer,
seldom to die.
It's in a rapid replication stage.
And at some point in time, your immune system was hindered.